[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSEPH VALENTE:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Joseph Valente.
MARY KOES: I'm Mary Koes.
JOSEPH VALENTE: And today we'll
be talking about audit logging.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
There should be a link
underneath your screen.
And we have Googlers
on standby to answer
all of your questions,
so let's get started.
So what are we going
to cover today?
First of all, we're going
to cover the basics.
We're going to look
at what audit logs are
and how you can
get them turned on.
Then we're going to go into
some more detailed ways
to use audit logs--
so setting up
alerting, exports, and storage.
Then we're going to look
at some advanced use cases,
like insider risk
and compliance.
And finally, we'll
head to your questions.
So let's go to the basics.
MARY KOES: All right,
so to start out,
I'm going to start out
talking about Stackdriver.
And you might be
asking, well, what
are we talking about
Stackdriver for?
I thought we were here
to talk about audit logs.
But all audit logs come through
the Stackdriver platform,
and specifically the
Stackdriver Logging platform.
So to give you a little bit of
an overview of what Stackdriver
is, it is a SaaS ops
suite from Google
that's used by
developers, operators
to monitor and troubleshoot
your applications,
whether they're running
on GCP, AWS, cloud data
infrastructure--
wherever it's hosted.
And our goal is to help
you keep all of your stuff
fast, available, and secure.
So there are a number
of different tools
in the Stackdriver toolkit--
six of them, actually.
Today we're going to be focusing
on monitoring and logging.
And those are the two
parts of the platform that
will allow us to
visualize our audit logs,
export them different
places, alert on them,
create charts from them,
all sorts of snazzy stuff.
And the other tools
in the toolkit
here are reporting, trace,
debug, and profiler.
We're going to save
for a later date.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Awesome.
So let's have a think
about audit logging.
What is audit logging?
It's an immutable audit
trail of all the actions
taken by anyone who interacts
with your data and systems
on GCP.
So you can think of it as a
record of who did what, where,
when, and why on your systems.
Audit logs are immutable,
and you'll get them for free
for 365 days for your
admin audit logs,
or for longer if you
want to pay to have
your ingestion of your
data access audit logs.
So let's look in a bit more
detail at how those work.
Admin activity audit logs
are the most basic audit logs
that come turned on
for all [? rights ?]
by default on the vast majority
of all your GCP services.
Like I said, we host
them for free for 3--
sorry, for 400 days now.
And you can see them in your
Stackdriver Logging console.
Data access audit logs
need to be turned on.
You pay for ingestion for each
of these data access audit
logs, but you don't
pay for storage.
We'll cover how you get
these turned on later.
But what these show
is an additional bit
of information around
who read or wrote data
from your data sources on GCP.
Finally, we now have
access transparency
logs as well, which cover
actions by Google Support
and Engineering.
So imagine a person created
a bucket on your GCP service
that created an admin
activity audit log.
Then someone uploaded some
data into that bucket,
read it, looked at the data
in the bucket a few times,
and created a few more
data access audit logs.
Let's say they were having
a problem with that data
and they needed to go and
get some help from support.
They call up Google Support, and
Google Support goes and looks
at some of the
settings on that bucket
to see if the appropriate
permissions were in place.
I just want to reiterate
Google Support can't
look at the data that's
inside your bucket,
but we want to log all
of this information
so that you can get a full
picture of your security
posture in GCP.
When the Google
Support technician
looks at the metadata
and ACLs on the bucket,
an access transparency
log is created
that you can also see in your
Stackdriver Logging console.
So let's talk about some of
the key features of these.
So like I said, these are
available for nearly every GCP
service in the case of your
admin activity and data access
audit logs.
Our access transparency logs are
only available on six services.
We just launched them
into beta two weeks ago,
but we're planning to add
a lot more new services
throughout the
rest of this year.
They have [? audit ?]
[? grade ?] protections,
so these logs are immutable.
Once you turn them on, you
can't actually delete them.
And the reason for
this is that we
want to make sure that
if a malicious insider
inside your company
is attempting
to cover their
tracks, these audit
logs can't be deleted by them.
So you always have a
record of what's happened.
Retention is 13 months--
400 days-- for admin activity
and access transparency logs.
And for data access
audit logs, the billing
is based on ingestion
and not retention.
So once you turn them on, we'll
charge you to ingest them,
and you can decide whether
to export them or put them
somewhere else.
And we'll talk about
how you can do that
later in this presentation.
Cool, so let's look at a demo of
how we can turn audit logs on.
We'll switch to our demo.
So what I've got open
here is just a console.
I've got the gcloud
SDK installed.
I'm going to call
get-iam-policy on the project
that I want to turn data
access audit logs on.
You'll see that there's
really no information there.
There's just your
basic IAM config.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to edit that to change
the IAM config to tell
GCP to turn audit logs on
for this particular project.
So I'm going to jump into
our documentation, which
you can see on our website.
You can look up Configuring Data
Access Audit Logs on our GCP
[? doc ?] [? site. ?] You can
turn them on for different
services.
There's different kinds
of audit logs, obviously,
that you can turn on, and
you can also exempt people.
I'm going to show you a sample.
There's a little
YAML sample here
that we can pull and
paste into our config file
to show you how this works.
So as you can see in
this little config,
I'm turning on audit logs for
all services in all types--
so admin read, data
write, and data read.
But you'll notice there's
also another audit
log configs object
at the bottom that
creates an exemption for a
particular service account.
I'm going to go ahead and remove
that, because I don't actually
want to exempt anyone from
being able to write audit logs.
But you might like
to do that if there's
a service account that's
spewing a lot of audit
logs that are not
valuable to you.
So I've saved this
new config file.
I'm going to go ahead
and call setIamPolicy
on the same project,
and success.
I've set the new IAM config
and it shows that I've enabled
audit logs for all
services and all types--
admin read, data
write, and data read.
Let's see how this works.
So I'm now going to
go ahead and check
to see if the data access
audit logs are turned on
for this particular project.
I'm going to go into the storage
bucket that I have set up.
I've accessed this text
file, set this as text,
and now I'm going
to head to my logs
and see if it shows
up in my logs.
Click onto Stackdriver
Logging, and there we go.
I've got a get and
some list operations.
So we'll pause it
there before I leak
all of my personal information.
OK, so that is how you get data
access, audit logs turned on,
and admin read audit
logs turned on.
Like I said, admin access
write audit logs are turned
on by default. If you'd like
to turn on access transparency
logs, you can head to
the Google Cloud website.
Just look for the Access
Transparency product,
and there's a Request
Access button.
MARY KOES: All right, so next
up we have using our audit logs.
We're going to jump
into a demo, here.
All right, and so I'm going to
go over into my Cloud Console,
and I've got my Logs Viewer up.
I'm going to select my GCE VMs.
[INAUDIBLE] take a
look at all my GCE VMs.
So right now I'm seeing
all the logs that
are coming from these GCE VMs.
If I just want my
audit logs, I'm
going to select Activity here.
And I don't have
anything super recent.
That's OK.
I'll go ahead and load
some older logs here.
And let's say that
I get a call from--
oops.
There we go.
Let's say I got a call from
one of my developers who says,
hey, what's going on?
My VM is gone.
I thought it should be there.
And I say, all right, well,
what's your VM's name?
And they tell me it is MyVM2.
So I'm going to search
for MyVM2 in my logs.
Let's take a look to see
what's going on here.
And I'm going to look
through all of the audit logs
and see if I can find
out who took an action
or if the system took an action
to get rid of this VM here.
All right, live demo,
that's always cool.
Whoops.
JOSEPH VALENTE: That's how
you know it's live, right?
MARY KOES: That's how
you know it's live.
All right, so I can see a number
of different things going on
here.
But the thing that's
particularly interesting to me
is in these audit
logs, I can see
it was created on April 8
around 11 o'clock at night.
And on April 10 I can see
that it was actually deleted.
So let me dive into
that specific log entry
and take a look at
what's going on here.
You can see there
is a lot of data.
But very specifically, I
can see somebody called
the delete function on this.
And I can see the principal
email is mkoes@google.com.
Oh, that's me.
Yeah, I actually accidentally
deleted this person's VM.
But we have a log entry
of that so we know
exactly who took which entry.
So that's all nice, but
one of the common use
cases we hear from
our customers is
they don't want to
just be able to use it
for diagnostics
purposes, but they also
want to be able to
create proactive alerts
on certain types of audit logs.
So a common thing that
we would hear maybe
is users who want
to maybe create
an alerting policy
anytime a user
is added to a new
IAM role when they're
outside of their organization.
So it's kind of
complicated, but that's OK.
We can handle it.
Let's start out with going
to our IAM section here.
And I'll open that in a new tab.
And I'm going to, just
to kind of test this out,
add a new member,
auditlogsrock@gmail.com.
And I'm going to
select a role for this,
and grant them a role.
So I'm going to
go ahead and save,
and then I'm going
to go back to my logs
and take a look to see if I
can see what happened there.
So I know there's something
to do with auditlogsrock.
Now when I search
that, oh look, I'm
searching through my GCE VM
instances, which isn't actually
where I want to be looking.
So I'm going to convert to
the advanced filter here,
and I can see I have a more
advanced query language
that I can interact with.
So rather than look for
everything just on my GCE
instances, I'm going to
look for auditlogsrock
across everything.
And here I can see that we
recently added auditlogsrock
to a set IAM policy, and I can
see kind of the details here.
So I'm going to go ahead and
click on Show Matching Entries.
I always want this just to
be limited to my audit logs.
So I'll add that into my filter.
And then I might
also want to say--
I don't want to limit it
just to auditlogsrock,
but let me find out
exactly where that is.
So I'm going to look
into here and look
at my service data, policy
delta, my binding deltas.
And I can see the member
who was added here
is auditlogsrock@gmail.com.
So if I click Show Matching
Entries for just a moment,
I can change this so
that I exclude anything--
so I'm adding my not here--
that matches user
colon, and then I'm
going to say my
organization is @google.com.
Let me try making sure we still
see the right audit log there.
All right, good, so
that's appropriate.
From here I can, in one
step, just create a metric.
So what this will do is for
any new log entries coming in,
we will check what
logs-based metrics
we actually have, and if it
matches any, will count that.
So we'll basically be
counting any incoming log
entries that match this filter.
So I'm going to name it
LogsFromOutsideMyOrg.
And that's it.
I'm going to go ahead
and create the metric.
There are some more
advanced things
you can do with
logs-based metrics,
but we'll save that
for a different day.
And you can see this is actually
my second logs-based metric
here.
And now what I want to
do is actually create
an alerting policy from it.
So what I just created
was LogsFromOutsideMyOrg.
I'm going to go ahead and create
an alert from this metric.
So this is popping up, the
Stackdriver Monitoring console.
Remember we said there
are two different tools
within Stackdriver that
we're going to be using.
One is Monitoring.
The other is Logging.
Also, if you recall, we said
logs-based metrics will only
apply for data going forward.
So we just created
this logs-based metric.
We won't see any data here.
That's OK.
But I want to say, I want to be
alerted anytime this happens.
So if I see even one ever, I
want to be alerted for that.
And we'll say
across any resource.
I'm going to go ahead and
save the alerting condition.
So this is a Stackdriver
Monitoring alerting UI.
The way it works is we're going
to define these conditions.
If those conditions
are violated,
then we'll automatically
create an incident
and send some notifications.
So the next thing we need to
do is choose what notifications
we need to send here.
So we have a number of
different notification options--
email, our Cloud
Console mobile app.
Some other commonly used
ones are webhooks, Slack,
and PagerDuty.
In this case I'll
leave it at email,
and I will send it to
auditlogsrock@gmail.com.
I could add another
notification if I wanted.
I can add some documentation.
Someone added a policy
outside our org.
Go talk to them.
I could link to a
playbook here, as well.
And then I can name the policy.
So alert if users
outside my org.
And go ahead and save my policy.
All right, so now let's
go ahead and test it.
I'm going to go back to
our IAM page over here.
And I'm going to
go ahead and test
this again by adding
another member-- so
auditlogsrock@gmail.com.
All righty.
And I'll set Random Other
IAM role, and save that.
It should take us
just a minute for that
alerting policy to fire.
So while we're doing
that, let's go ahead
and talk about another
common use case
that we hear from
customers, which is great,
it's fantastic that we can
alert on our audit logs.
But what I really want
to also be able to do
is to do some automation
based on our audit logs.
And so here's where the power
of the Stackdriver Logging
platform is really powerful.
So we're going to
start out with--
what we're going to
do is we're going
to take those audit
logs that are coming in.
We're going to export
the matching logs
that we care about
to a Pub/Sub channel,
and we'll use Cloud Functions
to take action based on that.
So again, the kind
of flow is audit logs
are automatically generated.
That's fantastic.
They'll come in to
Stackdriver logging.
From there, they will
go to this log sink
that we need to create.
And then from there
they'll go to Pub/Sub.
We'll use Cloud
Functions to do whatever
kind of crazy
processing we dream up.
So for this example,
let's say every time
we start up a new VM we
want to apply a label
or maybe check to see
if that label exists,
and if it doesn't, then
automatically apply that label.
For example, say that
the environment is prod.
So the first thing we
need to go ahead and do
is create an export.
So you'll see over here, we
started out in the logs viewer.
We tested out logs metrics.
That was how we created
alerting policies.
From there, we're
going to do exports.
So I'm going to go over
into our Exports tab.
I have a couple of exports
already set up here.
Similar to how
logs-based metrics work,
exports also work only kind of
going forward for log entries.
And so right before
this I did create
the log sink just to make
sure that everything works.
So I'm going to go ahead and
take a look at that log sink.
And what I'm saying
is, I want anything--
the colon here does
a substring match,
so anything where the log name
matches my activity logs--
and anything where the audit
logging protoPayload.methodName
is insert.
And that's the kind of keyword
that you'll see in our docs
is used when a
new VM is created.
And I also want to make sure
that we actually have the type.
This colon star means
this field exists.
So if I load--
oops, I haven't created
anything recently,
but let me go ahead and
load some older logs here
and take a look.
And we can see some
examples of this
as I've spun up, in testing,
some different logs.
So you can see I created
MyVM1, MyVM2, MyVM3.
Each of these already
happened back in time,
but if I create the
next one, MyVM4,
then it should automatically
show up here on the sink.
All right, so I have
my sink working.
From here, I'm actually going
to go to Cloud Functions.
So there was one other thing
I wanted to call out here
for just a moment.
The other important
thing about the sink
is where it actually goes.
So if I edit the
sink one last time,
I had to specify the filter.
I also had to
specify the location.
So I chose Cloud Pub/Sub.
My options were BigQuery,
Cloud Storage, and Pub/Sub.
This custom destination will
allow you to create and export
to a different location, so for
example to a different project
or even to a different org
if you really wanted to
and your permissions
were set up correctly.
BigQuery and Pub/Sub
happen in real time.
Cloud Storage is batched
about once per hour,
and so it takes a
few hours for those
logs to show up
in that location.
And we'll talk
about why you might
want to use these other export
locations in a minute here,
but we'll focus on Cloud
Pub/Sub for right now.
And as soon as I
chose Cloud Pub/Sub,
I had the option to either
use an existing Pub/Sub
feed, auditLogPubSub,
or to create a new one.
So I'm going to use the one
I already have created here.
So now I'm going to go
over to my Cloud Functions.
All right, and creating
the Cloud Function
took a little bit of thought,
so I've done that ahead of time
here.
And you can see I've got
this Cloud Function called
processAuditLogs.
I'm going to go ahead
and click on it.
I can see in the last hour it
hasn't had to process anything
at all here.
If I zoom out for a few
days, we should probably see,
yep, I processed a few
things a couple of days ago
and one not that long ago
just to make sure everything
was still working.
I can take a look
at the trigger.
So you can set
Cloud Functions up
to trigger on different things.
In this case, we're triggering
on the auditLogPubSub topic
that we had specified
in our log sink.
Now let's take a
look at the source.
All right, so what this
Cloud Function is going to do
is act on a Pub/Sub message.
We know that the log entries
are what will be coming in
on that Pub/Sub message.
So we're going to parse
that Pub/Sub message.
Take a look at the
log entry here.
We have some auth stuff that
I took from our handy examples
in our documentation.
And then we're going to check to
make sure that this is actually
a valid log entry for us.
In this case, we only care
about new VMs, so only
things where it is
actually a log entry
and there is actually
a request field.
And the method name
of that request field
is compute.instances.insert.
And then we'll actually pull
the name of the VM out of there.
And in order to add
a label to that VM,
we need to first get the labels
that exist on that VM already,
and then we can add
new ones if needed.
And so that's what
we're doing here.
We're doing a get on that
new VM, logging things if we
see an error.
We have to pull out
that fingerprint,
and that's what we
use to actually create
the new label down here
where environment is prod.
And then we'll say,
yay, we set the labels
and exit out of here.
So with that, let's go ahead and
go back to our Compute console.
And I'm going to
create a new instance.
And I'll call this MyVM4.
Go ahead and set
it as a small one.
And we'll go ahead
and create it.
So it'll take just a
moment for that to spin up.
And I should be able to
see it in my audit log.
So let's hop over to
the logs viewer here.
And I'm going to go
back to all my logs.
And let me switch
to the basic mode.
All right, and so
now, again, I'm
seeing all my logs
from all of my VMs.
Instead, I'm just going to
take a look at my audit logs.
And indeed I see that
a new instance, MyVM4,
was inserted just a moment ago.
So now I can go back
to my Cloud Function.
And we'll take a look
at the Cloud Function
and what it's processed.
And you can see, oh yeah,
it did see something
just a moment ago.
So should really have left the
tab open, but that's all right.
Go back to Compute Engine here.
Take a look at MyVM4.
And you'll remember I didn't
add any labels whenever
I created this.
So if I want to make sure
that this worked correctly,
Show Info Panel.
And we can see it worked.
We created a key
with environment
and the value is prod.
So you can use this for
lots of different things.
If a firewall rule is
incorrectly configured,
automatically remove that.
Or again, if we think
about the example
we just did with our
alerting, if someone
adds a user who isn't
part of the organization,
maybe you change the role
that was just created.
The kind of
possibilities here are
endless because we have
so many different APIs
that you can use.
So speaking of the thing
that we were alerting on,
let's just hop over to the
email for auditlogsrock,
and we can see we should have
received an email saying,
hey, there was an issue.
And indeed I created a
previous alerting policy.
So you see it represented
a few times here,
but I can drill into
this and it does
let me know that the
alerting policy was created,
that the issue
was detected here.
Great.
So, moving along then, that was
alerting and creating exports.
I mentioned there are a few
different types of exports.
Another type of export that
you might choose to use
is BigQuery.
And so I have, if
I go to My Exports,
I can see a number of--
I've created this thing
for my BigQuery audit logs,
and I could use BigQuery to
actually explore the logs here,
as well.
Let's see.
And then the last thing
that I want to show
is suppose I wanted to
send all of my old logs
or all of my audit logs to
GCS for compliance purposes.
I could use a log
sink for that as well.
So same sort of process
would hold here.
I would choose which
logs I want to export.
And in this case here,
I'll export all of my logs
from all of my GCE VMs.
And I'll select a
new storage location.
I'll have to create a
new one, AllGCELogs.
And I can then go
ahead and create this,
and that way all my future logs
will be put into that location.
The thing that we hear
from customers a lot
though is, all
right, that's cool,
but I have an organization
with thousands of projects.
How do I make sure that I have
log sink set up on all of them?
And so we have a really cool
tool called Aggregated Exports
which will allow
you to manage that.
So what Aggregated Exports
will allow you to do--
and you can do this via the API
or via the gcloud command-line
interface--
is I can create a log
sink either at the folder
or at the organization level.
And if I say
include-children, then it
will not only get the logs
from all of the VMs that I have
or all of the projects
that I have today
but also from any new project
that's spun up in the future.
All right, and with that let's
move on to advanced use cases.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Cool.
So Mary's looked
at some of the ways
that we can set up alerting
and exports and storage.
Let's look at some
of the use cases
that we might use those in.
So the first one we have
is insider risk audits.
So we all have sensitive
data in our businesses.
We all want to make
sure it's protected.
But obviously we need people
to actually go and use
that data from time to time.
So what if you want to put
a little bit of an extra bit
of security on top
of that and audit
some of those accesses that
are particularly sensitive?
So let's say that you
receive in the security team
a tip-off that one
of your employees
has been looking
up customer data
without a legitimate
business purpose?
You might have all of your
storage systems inside GCP.
You've configured
data-access audit logging,
and it's piping it all
into Stackdriver Logging.
As Mary showed you,
you can set up exports.
So you can export them
into an external sim tool
if that's how you'd
like to view your data,
or you can even export
them into BigQuery if you
prefer to use BigQuery.
Once you've done that, you
can search for an actor using
the principal-email field.
You can audit all the resources
that that person has accessed
in the last seven
days or month, however
long it is you're
auditing their behavior.
And then in some
cases you can even
go ahead and audit
the full request
and respond strings,
which we have
available in a lot
of our audit logs.
So you can get a true picture
of exactly what people have
been doing on your service.
For compliance, we often
have companies contacting
us talking about how
they need to retain
audit logs to comply with
whatever policy or regulation
that they are subject to.
For this you might enable
all the audit logs on all
of your services, for example.
That would go into
Stackdriver Logging,
and then you would configure
your export this time
into just the GCS bucket.
And you might configure the
IAM policy on that GCS bucket
to be highly restricted,
so only someone maybe
in your legal team
can access it.
And then also you would enable
data-access audit logging
on that bucket
itself to make sure
that you have an
audit trail of who has
been accessing the audit logs.
From that you can generate
reports from your logs,
turn them over to
auditors, or retain them
for a custom period.
You can retain them
for however long
you want in your GCS bucket.
MARY KOES: One
other cool feature
that we didn't talk about but
just kind of to call out here
is we have a feature
called logging exclusions.
So if you want to store
those logs in a GCS bucket
but you don't want to pay for
those in Stackdriver Logging--
specifically for those
data-access logs,
which can be really
high volume--
you can use your export
along with a feature called
exclusions and say,
keep those logs out
of Stackdriver Logging.
Because the export happens
before the exclusion,
those will still be
exported while you
can choose not to pay for
them in Stackdriver Logging
if you want those for
compliance purposes
but don't need them for alerting
or other Stackdriver-related
functionality,
searching, et cetera.
Cool.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Great.
OK, so stay tuned for some live
Q&A. We'll back in less than a
minute to answer your questions.
OK, and we're back.
Thanks for asking all
these amazing questions.
We're going to go ahead and
answer a few of them now.
So the first one is, what
if I want to delete my audit
logs and not be
charged for them?
MARY KOES: Great question.
We get this one a lot.
So the answer is that
audit logs are charged only
based on-- all logs are charged
only based on ingestion.
So you don't need to worry about
managing the volume of data
that is being stored.
And also remind folks
that we only charge
for the data-access logs or
the access-transparency logs,
not for the
admin-activity logs which
are available kind
of free of charge
as part of your use of
the Google Cloud Platform.
JOSEPH VALENTE:
One other thing I'd
like to add there is just
around deleting projects.
So as you'd imagine,
when you delete a project
it will delete the information
around that project.
And that will include the logs
that are inside your project.
So do make sure that you
have the appropriate controls
in place to prevent that
from happening if that's
something you'd like to avoid.
So the next question is, can
I write my own audit logs?
MARY KOES: So we do support,
via the logging API,
writing all sorts
of different logs.
Audit logs are kind of a special
type of log that we've defined,
and we write to them on your
behalf as part of Google Cloud
Platform.
So you can't write your
own audit logs per se,
but you can create your own
logs that do anything else
you want to capture there.
And we support that via API.
We also have a logging agent.
You can send that through
our client library.
So there are lots
of different ways
to get your own logs into the
Stackdriver Logging platform.
JOSEPH VALENTE: Great.
What actual information
is contained
inside the audit logs?
Do you have the location
of the accessor?
MARY KOES: Want
to take that one?
JOSEPH VALENTE: This is
a really good question.
So you can read about
all the information
that's contained inside the
audit logs on our Google Cloud
Platform audit-logging
documentation page.
There's different
types of information
inside each of the three
different types of logs.
So in your
admin-access API logs,
there's more information
around people
who have performed things like,
as Mary was showing you before,
creation and deletion
of objects and so forth.
Your data-access
logs, you're going
to get more information
about a resource that
was read or written to.
In the access-transparency logs,
you get similar information.
However, you do get
slightly less information.
While in your admin activity
and data-access logs,
you will get the principal
email of the actor.
In your access-transparency
logs you
won't get the principal
email of the Google employee
who performed the
access, but you
will get the location of
where they accessed it from.
Unfortunately, we don't have
that information available yet
inside our admin-activity
or data-access logs.
But if it's of
interest to you, please
feel free to reach out to us.
We'd love to hear from you.
And with respect to
the access-transparency
logs as well, when we show you
the location of the Googler,
we also show you
the desk location
where that Googler is
typically situated.
So you'll be able to
see that the Googler was
in the US at the time,
but their desk location
is typically in Canada.
That's something that we've
heard from some customers
as being helpful for
compliance reasons,
but your mileage may vary.
MARY KOES: But if we
have any customers who
are concerned about capturing
the location of the accessor
for other logs, that generally
isn't something we capture,
right?
JOSEPH VALENTE:
That's right, yes.
MARY KOES: And
last question-- are
audit logs available
for all our services?
JOSEPH VALENTE: Tough one.
They're available for
almost all of our services.
We're hopefully going
to be able to announce
later this year that they
are available for all
of our services.
Right now you can head to
our Google Cloud Platform
documentation to see the
full list of services that
have logs available
for them, and also you
can read what the state of those
audit-logging integrations are.
So in some cases
they may be in GA.
For some other cases we may be
only producing them in beta.
So you might not be
able to rely on them
as much as you can for
a GA-style audit log.
However, you can
be fairly confident
that, for most services,
by the end of this year
we should have
audit-logging coverage,
at least for admin-activity
and data-access audit logging.
With respect to the
access-transparency logs,
those are only available for
six services at the moment.
They're available on Google
Cloud Storage, Google App
Engine, IAM, Key Management
Service, Persistent Disk, and--
have I said them all?
I think I have.
The full list is
available online.
You can go and head to our
Google Cloud Platform products
page and read on the
access-transparency product
page which services
they're available for.
We're constantly
adding new services
to our access-transparency
integrations.
We have another four
coming this quarter,
and we're going to have a
lot more added this year.
So stay tuned if you're
interested in that.
You can definitely take
a look at our website.
And if you want, we can
turn them on for you.
One thing I will note that I
don't think we've had a chance
to say yet, though, with respect
to the access-transparency logs
is that you will need to
have gold or platinum support
enabled to turn those on.
Once you have gold and
platinum support enabled,
you can turn
access-transparency logs on,
and we'll collect and
store those logs for you
free of charge.
But unfortunately, we don't
yet offer this service
to customers who don't have
those support packages enabled.
MARY KOES: Great, thanks.
JOSEPH VALENTE: OK,
I think that's all
we have question-wise.
As always, you know
where to contact us.
You can get more support
from Google Support.
But otherwise, thanks so
much for participating
in this webinar.
MARY KOES: Thank you.
JOSEPH VALENTE: We hope
you've had an amazing journey
on this audit-logging
journey with us.
Please tune in next Tuesday for
the next episode of Cloud Live
OnAir, and thanks very much.
MARY KOES: Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]